here's a case study of five devices once
again I really encourage you to see who
the researchers are in the visual index
at the end of this material this is
pretty wonderful stuff so we have five
devices three on the right and two on
the left notice the composition not
boringly lined up in a row so this image
was taken in let's call it the default
mode as most of the others so to remind
you this is with reflected light coming
from below the glass the light bounces
off the device and is read by the sensor
below again pretty standard setting on
your flatbed scanner as if you were
scanning a document now look what
happens when we use transmitted light
that is light from above where the
information is still captured from
beneath you'll see that the left two are
just rectangles of black and that's
because of course that the light is
prevented from being transmitted through
the solid silicon chip no light is
reaching the sensor whereas the others
on the right are showing some details
since they are somewhat transparent
remember the sensor is beneath the glass
so as we zoom in the slides on the right
show some pretty interesting detail
detail that we would not see with
reflected light you might want to pause
the video here to see the differences
the luxury here is having the ability to
transmit light through your sample my
flatbed scanner has a light source in
the cover I set my scanner in the
transmitted light mode as if we were
scanning film or other transparent
material but you should play around with
your own setups for example here I just
open the cover of the scanner the
setting in the scanner is set to scan
with reflected light this is one of
those examples when experimenting can
give us an unusual result something new
and possibly useful ok let's take a look
at biological growth in a petri dish for
another case study this is showing ecoli
growing under 42
editions I put the petri dish on the
scanner and once again use the default
reflected light captured at a pretty
high resolution around 400 Meg's for the
whole image looks good but as we zoom in
we're getting some dust and dirt on the
surface of the petri dish I'm not happy
about that so I decided to try
transmitted light as we just saw before
in our previous case study my scanner
remember has a light source in its cover
giving me transmitted light that is
light coming from above using this
transmitted light approach makes sense
for bacterial and biological growth in
Petri dishes if you don't have a scanner
that has the light in its cover then you
might have some luck with reflected
light but I wanted to make a particular
point here here I'm using a mobile phone
camera making a picture that is pretty
ok just quickly showing what's going on
here in the petri dish but compare it to
this high resolution scanned image using
transmitted light and it's a whole
different world I'm overlapping hear the
phone image over the transmitted scanned
image so that you can see the important
point here the phone image is
considerably smaller in terms of its
file size so that when we zoom in
closely on the computer screen with each
of these images we see pretty
significant differences in resolution in
the scanned image of about 400 Meg's you
can see remarkable detail as we move
into the image but the phone image well
let's just say is not totally remarkable
so it depends on what you'll be using
these images for I really do want to
encourage you to get the very best image
you can from the very beginning it's the
difference between spending one minute
on an image and six minutes let's say my
hope is that you see that spending the
additional five minutes is pretty much
worth the time don't you think
you